- When we made our decision
in December of 2017,
I kept track of some of those predictions.
You're going to have to pay $5 per tweet,
you're not going to be
allowed to post on Instagram.
One of my favorites, the
Senate Democratic Caucus
Twitter account said,
"The internet will work
"one word at a time."
Or one of my favorites,
this is the end of the
internet as we know it.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and this
is the "Rubin Report."
Make sure that you're subscribed
and click the notification bell.
Otherwise, we're just talking
to ourselves over here.
And joining me today is the chairman
of the Federal Communications
Commission, aka the FCC.
Ajit Pai, welcome to the "Rubin Report."
- Thanks so much for having me on, Dave.
- I am thrilled to have you here,
because I don't know that
I've ever had a guest
that probably has more
power to do more things
relative to the thing that I do than you.
So that's a lot of pressure, my friend.
- A lot of pressure, but hopefully
I will be able to equip
myself well, we'll see.
(laughing)
- We shall see.
Okay, before we do anything
else, there is a meme of you.
- (laughing) So I hear, yes.
- You are a meme'd person
because you have a giant mug,
a coffee mug, a Reese's
Pieces logo coffee mug.
And this thing has caught
fire on the internet.
How did this even come to pass?
Why do you have this mug?
- It's so random, so about 10 years ago,
I was up in Hershey, Pennsylvania,
with my then girlfriend, now wife,
and I love coffee, I love
Reese's peanut butter cups,
and I saw this giant mug, and I thought,
oh, this is the perfect mind
meld, and so I just bought it.
At our FCC meetings,
sometimes they would drag on
for a while, and I'm an
inveterate coffee drinker,
so I just brought this mug
down to our monthly meetings,
started drinking out of it,
and then John Oliver did this skit
about two and a half
years ago, mocked the mug,
and ever since then, I'm
always getting these emails,
tweets, and whatnot, "You and your mug."
The mug was the innocent party,
so gonna be collateral damage.
- It's a big mug, too.
It's also a giant mug.
- It is.
I actually measured it out.
It's six liquid cups.
- Wow.
- So I go through about
two cups of those a day,
two mugs a day of coffee,
and so it's a fair amount
of caffeine that's
going through the veins.
But it's kind of funny how it's
taken on a life of its own.
- All right, well, you
kept the coffee mug.
It's our coffee mug.
We tried to buy you a Reese's
coffee mug for the show,
but we were on a time crunch,
so we couldn't pull it off.
But...
- Ah, yes.
- I have brought you Reese's pieces.
- (laughing) Just in time for Halloween.
- Just in time for Halloween,
so I'll just put that there,
and if you so choose to eat a Reese's
throughout the interview, feel free.
- Well, if you don't mind.
- Have I given you coffee?
I don't know what you're drinking there.
(laughing)
- No, I could take it
intravenously, if I could.
But no, I hope you don't
mind if I maybe take a break
every now and then and
just start munching on it.
- That's fine, okay.
There's a ton of stuff I wanna
talk to you about obviously.
I've never been more
sure that either YouTube
is going to completely crush
this episode in the algorithm
or make sure that everyone sees it
to thus prove that they
don't mess round with things.
So I wanna spend, obviously, a lot of time
talking about tech
regulation and all that,
and a little bit about your history
and what the FCC was set out
to do versus what it does now,
and all of those things.
But sort of broadly to start,
how much time do you
guys now have to spend
on just purely the tech
issues related to censorship
rather than just pretty much anything else
that the FCC has ever done?
- It's a decent amount of time,
not so much because we
directly regulate them.
Under the current law
we don't have authority
to regulate some of the
Silicon Valley tech giants,
but in part because we do
regulate, broadly speaking,
the infrastructure of the internet,
and issues like net neutrality, of course,
have been at the fore
for a couple of years.
- Oh, we're gonna talk about that.
We're still alive.
- (laughing) I had a feeling.
- We're still here, man, I feel terrific.
- Somehow the internet still works.
So we do monitor a lot of
these issues that have come up,
and it's fascinating how much
the conversation has changed.
When I started talking
about this two years ago,
it was thought to be sort
of an outlier opinion
to go after some of the
Silicon Valley tech giants
for some of the policies
or the lack of transparency in particular,
and now you see members of both parties
in both houses of Congress,
people on the campaign trail,
the average American consumer is saying,
"What's going on here?
"We want more insight
into how these companies
"are doing business."
And so we spend a fair
amount of time on that.
There are other issues though
that occupy the lion share of my time,
5G, closing the digital divide,
tacking unwanted robocalls,
doing those kinds of
bread and butter attacks
that the FCC has been entrusted with.
- Right, okay, so let's
just back up fully.
Just tell people that have no idea.
They hear FCC, they're not
exactly sure what it means,
what it's supposed to do.
What was the FCC designed
to do originally.
- So it was designed in 1934
to regulate the radio airwaves
and the telephone system,
the primary means of
communication back then.
Our statute is called the
Communications Act of 1934.
That act has been updated over the years,
most recently in 1996 in substantial part.
Now our jurisdiction has
grown over the years.
It's not just radio and
TV and telephone now.
Of course, we have jurisdiction
over satellite issues,
cable companies, to some
extent, internet infrastructure.
We're composed of five commissioners,
each of which has to be
nominated by the president,
confirmed by the Senate.
One commissioner is
designated as the chairman,
and that happens to be me right now.
I'm very blessed to be in that position.
There is a huge staff,
about 1,500 people or so,
to help us do all of the work
across these different areas.
They do fantastic work,
from volunteering to serve
in Puerto Rico after Hurricane Maria
to going to tribal reservations
in the mountain West
to help get broadband to
these hard-to-serve areas.
They are the eyes and
ears of the commission.
I'm at the top of the
pyramid, so to speak,
but they really deserve all the credit
for the good work we do.
- How'd you get involved in the FCC?
What made you the chairman of the FCC?
- Honestly, a complete accident.
Honestly, I became a lawyer
after graduating from college,
much to my parents' chagrin,
I didn't go to medical school.
But trying to live up to--
- [Dave] Is that tough for Indian parents?
- It was an interesting conversation
when I told them I was going to law--
- Ah, he's gonna be a
lawyer, not a doctor.
That's like a big hit, right?
- I still remember my
graduation party after college.
My parents organized a little
party for me in my hometown,
and one of my parents'
friends came and said,
"Oh, it's okay, not everyone
can get into medical school."
It was like a nice little pat on the back.
- That's hilarious.
- It's sort of funny,
every now and then, I try
to explain to my parents
what it is I do, and when I told them
I was gonna be nominated for this position
by President Obama back in 2011,
my mom's first three
questions outta the gate were,
is this a full-time job, does it pay,
and if it doesn't work out, can
you go back to the law firm?
She still wasn't quite sure
what it was that I did,
but I finally got across that it's like--
- That's actually hilarious,
you show her the letter from Obama,
and it's like, is this a full-time job?
- Yeah, I told her this is a real job,
and even then, for a while,
she wasn't sure what I did.
But a couple of years ago, I
was in LA for some meetings
and was going to see Judge Judy,
because I'm a huge Judge Judy fan,
and I told my mom on a Friday,
"Hey, I'm meeting Judge Judy on a Monday."
She canceled all of her
patients for Monday,
flew down to LA with me, and
she got to meet the judge.
She never told me afterward,
but her friends told me,
"Ajit, she's so proud of you."
- That's it.
- You got her in to see Judge Judy.
Not getting nominated by the president,
not closing the digital
divide, it's Judge Judy,
the highest court in the land,
getting her into that courtroom,
that was an accomplishment.
- At the end of the day, it's
still about parental approval.
- Yeah, so I think the candle still burns.
Hopefully, after this job is over,
I think she may want me
to go to medical school,
but for better or worse,
I'm in this role for now.
- Yeah, okay, so as the guy in this role,
can you explain a little bit
about your just personal philosophy
when it comes to what should be regulated,
what should be completely
left to the market,
and where those two things kinda meet?
- Yeah, so I have some basic
principles that guide my work
across these different areas
that we've talked about.
Fairly simple principles,
but I think they're important
for regulators to keep in mind.
One is that markets, not
preemptive regulation,
have delivered far more value
for American consumers over time.
And number two, the rule
of law really matters.
Administrative agencies like
ours can't just make it up.
The law has been set by Congress
and enacted by the president.
Ultimately, we can't make a decision
that doesn't have a grounding in law.
And third, and increasingly
importantly in this field,
we have to respect basic
principles of economics.
Things might seem like great ideas,
but if the cost benefit
analysis doesn't work,
if the different economic principles
that apply to our work aren't respected,
ultimately, you'll have a
very elegant plan on paper
that ends up foundering
on the rocks of reality.
So we try to respect
those three principles
in everything we do, and it's not easy.
Oftentimes, you're going to
make a lot of people unhappy,
but our job at the end of the day
is to deliver value for
the American consumer,
even when or especially when
it might not be popular.
- Does it strike you that your job
or anyone that's in government
that has anything to do with regulation
that the optics of the job
seem much harder now.
- Oh my god, yeah.
- Where 30 years ago, it's like, okay,
you're regulating the airwaves,
there's a couple of channels,
we're on our way to cable,
but if you do something, like the pushback
is only gonna be a certain amount
because it's just how it is.
There's only a limit, you
might get a letter in the mail
or something like that, or some
phone calls to your office,
where now everything that you guys do,
and almost anyone that's in
the public eye at any level,
it becomes like an absolute firestorm.
It must complicate the
job at a certain level.
- I think it does, and that's
actually a very good point.
So I've gotten to know all
of my living predecessors,
save one, going all the
way back to Newt Minow,
who was President Kennedy's
first FCC chairman
from '61 to '63.
- Wow.
- I had lunch with him
a couple of years ago
and was talking about some of
the things we're working on
and how exposed the job was, social media
and cable news networks,
hovering stuff and all the rest.
He stopped me and he said,
"I don't know how I
could do this job now."
Because back in the '60s,
three major broadcast channels,
your local radio station
and your local newspaper,
and that was pretty much it.
I mean, satellite hadn't
really taken off yet,
cable wasn't a real thing,
and so it's just a very different job now,
and that raises a lotta challenges.
Everything we do is
going to be scrutinized
and there's going to be a
lot of commentary about it.
I think it's fair to say the
FCC is much better known now
than it's ever been known before.
That does have some positive impacts.
I try to talk about the
positive things we do as well.
But there's no question that the exposure
for this position, for
our agency generally,
has made it a lot more
challenging than it used to be.
- How much is the sorta
changing technology
kind of effect what you do,
or sort of expose the way
things were done in the past?
So like right now, for example,
if we were doing this on television,
whether it was network or cable,
there's a lotta limitations
to what we could say,
the types of things we could
show, or things like that,
versus we're doing this on the internet.
We're on YouTube and podcast,
so there are some limitations, right?
Like we can't show porn
or something like that,
but pretty much it's
the Wild West out here.
So you guys have different
rules depending on the medium.
How sorta complicated is that these days?
- You've put your finger on
one of the central problems
in communications policy, is
that Congress sets the law,
and that law reflects a
snapshot of the marketplace
in a moment in time, and that snapshot,
especially in the technology sector,
very quickly becomes yellowed with age.
And so we hear constantly, for example,
from broadcast TV companies, saying,
"Look, we're competing in the same space
"with Google and Facebook
and other companies
"who don't face the
same legacy regulations
"that we have to deal with,
you need to change that."
And different sectors of the
economy say the same thing.
There's always the problem of government
trying to fit the square
peg of the marketplace
into the round hole of the law.
- So what do you day to those
guys when they say that?
'Cause that's a pretty
compelling argument, I think.
I mean, sometimes now you watch,
like we have regulations on
what commercials could say
be on television versus the internet,
pretty much anything could be out there.
- So the way I think about
it, the thing I told my team
from the beginning and I've
told them every day since,
is think about where the
marketplace is right now.
How would you construct
a regulatory framework
to deal with the marketplace
as it stands today?
And to the maximum
extent permitted by law,
we should adjust our regulations,
modernize them to
reflect that marketplace.
And I rely on one of my
favorite political philosophers,
and I know he's somebody you've drawn
a tremendous amount of
wisdom as well, Yoda,
(Dave laughing)
who in "The Empire Strikes Back,"
when he's training Luke in Dagobah--
- I thought you were
maybe going John Locke,
but I'm willing to work with this.
- (laughing) No, much
more profound than that.
Private property, very important,
but Yoda, when he's
training Luke in Dagobah.
- Okay, now you've really got me.
- Yeah, and so at one point
when he's training Luke,
he says, "You must unlearn
what you have learned,"
and that is so true when
it comes to Washington.
The regulatory impulse is so strong.
When you see an Uber or a Lyft,
oh that's a taxicab company,
let's slap all the
taxicab regulations on it,
Airbnb, oh, that's a hotel company,
same thing in the telecom sector, too.
Let's try to shoehorn all
of these legacy regulations
onto these new companies
and to maintain those legacy regulations
on the established companies.
My goal is pretty simple, to
just modernize our regulations
to reflect marketplace we're in.
Unlearn what you have learned
when it comes to telecom policy
and you'll unleash all kinds
of innovation and investment
that ultimately benefits consumers.
We don't wanna disincentivize companies
from competing and innovating,
because ultimately the consumer welfare
is what is at stake here.
- More importantly than any of this,
where are you at with the new "Star Wars"?
- Yeah, I haven't really been a big fan,
except for, I will say, I
thought "Force Awakens" was okay.
- Yes, "Force Awakens" was fine.
- But I thought "Rogue
One," that was awesome!
- I need more force.
- Really?
- Yeah, without the force--
- That ending scene though was incredible.
- Yeah, no, the ending was amazing.
- Because then it really
feeds into that first scene
in the "Episode IV."
But no, "Force Awakens"
was pretty good, I thought.
- You give me two hours
of the last five minutes
of "Rogue One," two hours
of just an onslaught
and then I'm thrilled, but all right.
(laughing)
Let's not get lost there, 'cause I sense
we could probably do that
for a couple of hours.
So a lot of this is sort of just fighting
the Washington machine, right?
- Yeah.
- The machine itself is designed
to create regulation, right?
So they see something like Uber come out,
and now everyone loves Uber
and it's changing the business,
but now you've got all these interests
with the taxi companies,
and then suddenly you then
have to fight the impulse
to basically crush them too.
- That's a pretty amazing
position to be in.
- It's very difficult,
and there are two very
powerful forces in Washington.
One is regulatory inertia,
that it's very easy
to maintain the rules on the books
because they've always been on the books
and they should always
therefore be on the books.
But the other one is some
of the entrenched interest
that say, look, no matter,
any regulatory change
is going to disadvantage somebody,
and so they will complain.
Those people who are affected
will have a disproportionate voice.
They'll be very loud about it.
And so that's part of
the challenge as well,
to try to have the longterm value
of a greater number of people in mind
when we make our decisions.
- So let's talk about that a little bit,
the lobbying situation.
How much of the influence that hits you
is lobbyists from either
telecommunications companies
or free speech organizations
or whatever it might be?
- Yeah, every sector I
think has a grievance
to share with the
agency, but our goal is--
- Can you explain a little
bit about how it works?
So you're in your office,
your assistant says to you,
"You got a couple of meetings today,"
and now you know some
lobbyists are coming in.
What is the process actually like?
- So yeah, I have a lot
of meetings every day
that I'm in the office in Washington,
and what often happens is
that people sit on my couch,
very much like we're sitting here,
and they'll tell me, "Ajit,
you're doing a great job
"on this and that, and this and that.
"We are all in favor of this.
"We are big free market advocates.
"On this particular issue--"
- [Dave] (laughing)
There's a but go in there.
- "There's one little tweak,"
and it's amazing how
many times that happens.
I did a round table
recently out on the road,
and it was striking.
One of the biggest
innovations we've introduced,
we have a $10 billion subsidy fund,
known as the Universal Service Fund.
Typically this consisted of cutting checks
to rural telephone companies
and saying, "Vaya con dios,
"we hope you build broadband
networks with this funding."
One of the major innovations I introduced
about two years ago when
I just got on board was,
instead of just cutting a
check, let's have an auction,
a reverse auction, where
all kinds of companies
using different
technologies have to compete
for this funding and there's
a downward pressure on prices,
it's technologically neutral,
it saves the taxpayer money,
yada yada, much more
efficient serving the cause.
I was in this round table and they said,
"We love all the stuff you're doing
"on the Universal Service Fund.
"It might be helpful though to exempt us
"from the auction mechanism
because it'd just be..."
Look, I understand from
their business perspective,
it makes sense, but my goal can't be
to vindicate any private interest.
It is not to vindicate
any private interest,
it's to uphold the public interest,
and that's going to make
people unhappy in many cases
because many business
plans might not survive
or might not thrive in an environment
where that kind of competition
is embraced by the regulator.
- So let's back up a little
bit to your philosophy again,
which basically you're
saying free markets,
you want them to do as much as possible,
and yet you're the guy that has to come in
and give some regulation
around the public good.
What do you think would happen?
This is like sorta the
purist libertarian approach,
what do you think would happen
if just basically the
regulations just all disappeared
and just the free market just was allowed
to do whatever it wants
related to all of these
issues around communication?
What do you think
actually would happen?
- That's a good question.
That's a very good question.
- By the way, I'm gonna move
this because otherwise--
- (laughing) I know, I'm
very tempted, I gotta say.
- I realize that if we
leave this the entire time,
the amount of memes that will come out,
that you had an hour long conversation
with a Reese's bar on the table.
- Oh my god.
- So I'm just gonna...
- It's become the MacGuffin already
in the interview.
- (laughing) Yeah, exactly.
- For those film duffs out there.
- You can have it later.
- You promise?
- Well, let's just see how it finishes up.
- Okay, all right, we'll see how it goes.
But your question was about
the lack of regulation altogether,
and I'm not one who says necessarily
that we need to scrap everything.
For example, in terms of
setting spectrum policy,
it's important for us to coordinate
among different government
agencies and the private sector,
but I do think it would be
an interesting experiment
in some of these areas
if the government got out of the business.
I'll give you one example.
Back in 1975, one of my
predecessors instituted a rule
prohibiting newspapers and broadcast,
TV and radio stations, from combining,
because that was seen to be
detrimental to competition.
Does anyone really think in 2019
that local newspapers
or local radio stations
are the dominant force
in any particular market,
especially some of the smaller markets?
I don't really think so.
So if we got rid of regulations there,
I don't think it would lead
to all this consolidation.
To the contrary, it would
enable them to compete
with the Googles and the Facebooks
and the Pandoras and Spotifys and others
who are out there
distribution information.
To me at least I think it's an
interesting thought exercise,
and as that denominator,
so to speak, grows,
as more people start to
compete in the same space,
I think it's important for government
to have an intellectually
honest assessment
of what competition is.
That denominator is much broader
than broadcast radio, for example.
It's all those streaming
services and podcasts
and all the rest of it that people...
People just wanna consume information.
Information, honestly, is the
denominator in many cases.
- So I think there's
probably a certain amount
of people listening to this going,
"All right, he's down
with the free markets,
"he's trying to use the
light touch when possible.
"How was this guy nominated by Obama?
"This sounds more like say a conservative
"or a Republican approach?"
Can you talk about that a little bit?
- Yeah, so traditionally commissioners
who are in the minority, so the
FCC I should have backed up,
the five commissioners I mentioned,
three of whom are of
the president's party,
two are of the minority
party, the party out of power.
So I was nominated in
2011, confirmed in 2012,
for one of the minority party seats,
and by tradition going
back a couple of decades,
the Senate leader of
the party out of power
makes a recommendation to the White House
on who those minority
commissioners should be.
And so in my case, Senator
McConnell recommended
to President Obama, "We
recommend Ajit for this slot,"
and somehow I fell through the cracks.
- So the president still
has to say it's okay,
even though you're the ones
getting the minority slot.
That's kinda interesting.
- Right.
So it's a very interesting process.
- So you're saying he still has the power
to stop that minority person from coming?
- Theoretically, yes, and so fortunately,
I fell through the cracks.
I had good friends on
both sides of the aisle
and confirmed me unanimously,
so it wasn't an issue.
But it's a very interesting
model of governance,
and I think a lot of the
cabinet departments, of course,
which is just that of a secretary,
have a very different model,
where it's more of a single
person in charge of the agency.
- So how much then of
your job is coordinating
with the president?
From what I can understand,
it sounds like Trump
is probably more in line with
your philosophy around this,
but does that even matter that much?
Did you see a big difference
from when Obama was there to now?
- So that's an interesting point.
We are actually an independent agency,
so once we are confirmed by the Senate,
we're off to the races.
We don't answer to anybody.
We're independent from the administration,
independent from Congress,
although of course we respect--
- I assume they can create
headaches for you though.
- Oh, absolutely, and
there's certain issues,
especially when it comes
to security, for example,
or some spectrum issues
where we have to coordinate
with say the Department of Defense
or the National Security Council
where we do work with White House
and administration agencies all the time.
But one of the things that
the president-elect told me
when I interviewed for the
job in January 2017 was,
"I'm giving you this job because I believe
"you're going to do terrific things.
"Do the job, I'm trusting
you with this responsibility
"because I know you'll
execute as you see fit,
"and we'll back you up 100% of the way."
And so that's been largely
what it's all been about.
We've been pursuing a lot
of different initiatives,
and they have been supportive,
especially on things like 5G,
where we think it's a national priority,
not just an FCC priority,
for America to lead the world
in this next generation technology.
- So what's happening with 5G right now?
Because I think now in LA in
certain spots, I am seeing 5G.
It just pops up on my phone.
And I remember I was traveling last year
that certain cities I would get it.
And I'd be like, whoa, I didn't
even know this was a thing.
So how does that actually work
when you guys are trying to
build a nationwide network?
- Yeah, so 5G is going to be tremendous,
100 times faster speeds than
4G, if not quicker than that,
much lower latency, a quicker
responsiveness of the network,
and also all kinds of applications
we can't even dream of.
So we're just in the
early stages right now.
The wireless carriers are
doing some deployments
in major cities, including Los Angeles,
and we're hopeful that's going
to ramp up in the future.
I think we're gonna have
92 commercial deployments
across the country by
the end of this year.
Many more are coming.
And so our goal is to just put
the building blocks in place
for companies to innovate.
That involves spectrum.
We're getting a lot more spectrum
in the commercial marketplace,
held a big auction in January,
another one finished up in May.
The biggest auction in American history
is going to be on December 10th.
This year alone, we're
gonna push more spectrum
in the commercial marketplace
than is held by every mobile
broadband provider combined
when it came to office,
so huge influx of supply.
On the infrastructure side, too,
we're modernizing our rules
to recognize that small cells,
essentially infrastructure
that's no bigger
than say that basketball
shouldn't have to jump
through the same regulatory hoops
as a 200-foot cell tower.
And that's the kind of
thing that has real pop
here in LA in particular.
Just yesterday morning,
I was visiting a site
where they're deploying these small cells
in a lower income neighborhood,
thanks in part to the
regulatory streamlining
that we've done and the city of LA,
believe it or not, has done.
- They're helping you?
The city of LA is helping you?
- I've gotta say, Mayor Garcetti
has been a terrific partner on this issue.
Other cities have raised
a few more roadblocks,
but those cities that
are forward thinking,
that want their citizens
to benefit from 5G,
are adopting this more modern approach
to infrastructure deployment.
So overall I think the United
States is poised to lead,
but there are other countries
too, particularly China,
that would love to seize
the lead for themselves.
And so we're in an implicit
competition I think
with many countries and
regions around the world.
- Yeah, so right before we started,
we talked about this issue
with how China deals with
regulation differently,
and there are strengths
and weaknesses to it.
Can you explain that a little bit?
'Cause I think it's a
really fascinating flip
on the way we talk about
a lot of these issues.
- It is, so China of
course is not a democracy.
Beijing can dictate not
just what policy priorities
the government should follow,
but also require all provinces,
all localities to fall into line,
and so of course since they don't observe
the same democratic nicety as we do,
in this case, they can simply fiat
we want to lead the world in 5G.
That means we're going
to pick the companies
that create the equipment
and subsidize them,
we're going to make sure
that our wireless carriers
can deploy at scale and
they don't have to jump
through these regulatory hoops,
and we are otherwise going to take
the steps necessary to preempt spectrum,
do the other things
necessary for 5G success.
- So that kinda sounds
good at some level, right?
- Right, but there are
of course some concerns
for those who share democratic values,
such as the United States.
Comparatively here, we have not just
federal regulatory
approval that's required,
state and local regulatory approval
that's required in many cases,
but also under a longstanding system
that the FCC set up many years ago,
any one of the 573
federally-recognized Indian tribes
also can have a bite of
the regulatory apple.
So one of the points I've made is that,
let's try to modernize that framework
to say that there's a
consistent level of regulation,
especially if you're a smaller company.
You don't have the lawyers and accountants
and compliance officers to jump through
all of these four different
layers for review,
and to the extent the capital is scarce
and work crews don't have to be hired
and networks don't have to be built,
I don't want that innovative spirit
to be directed to other parts of the world
where you can deploy at scale.
And that's part of the reason
why we've been trying to work
with localities, like LA,
to update that framework,
to make it more streamlined,
and just easier and cheaper
to build these networks.
- So in effect, while China can just say,
"All right, we're doing
this and no local province
"can do anything about it," and
while that may work for now,
it may make the process faster for now
while you have to deal with
local states and all that,
in the longterm, it probably
hurts their ability to innovate
because it's all coming from the top.
You guys have more of a
slog to fight through now,
but the hope is that you're
creating the groundwork sort of
to allow as much competition as possible
through the cell companies basically.
- Exactly right, and part of the reason
why I want this regulatory modernization
is not just to compete
with other countries,
but also because we recognize,
and this is one of the truths
that hardly ever gets
recognized in Washington,
that heavy-handed regulation
and multiple levels of regulation
disproportionately
affect smaller companies.
It's the larger companies that
have the compliance resources
that can jump through
a lot of these hoops.
Sure, it'll cost them money,
but they actually have
the resources to comply.
We don't wanna squeeze out some
of the smaller competitors,
and especially in the technology space.
We're trying to encourage
a lot more companies
to enter this space.
We haven't talked about space itself yet.
Satellite companies and
fixed wireless companies
and some of these newer companies,
they may not be able to get off the ground
if that regulatory framework is so onerous
that they can't raise capital,
they can't hire the lawyers,
and they can never deploy a product.
- Yeah, all right, so I'm
obviously gonna wanna spend
a lot more time talking about
the pure tech side of this
and the Silicon Valley side,
which is not as you said,
everyone thinks it's sort of your job,
but it's not quite your job.
But, wait, let's just do the
space thing for a minute,
'cause I think it's real interesting,
because it quite literally
is the next frontier,
if not the final frontier.
How in the world do you
sit down with people,
and you have government people now trying
to deal with the ideas that Elon Musk
and all of these people
are coming in with.
We're privatizing a
lot of the space stuff.
How do you even come to a basic place
where you can say, well,
you can kinda do this,
and I want you to be free,
but we can't totally do that.
I mean, how did that conversation even go?
- It's fascinating.
First of all, it's just
intellectually fascinating to me.
I've always loved space, and
the innovation that's happening
in space right now is just unprecedented.
The launches they're able
to do using reusable rockets
have really decreased the cost element
of launching these things into space.
- I mean, Elon literally
just sent a Tesla into orbit,
just 'cause he could do it.
(laughing)
Do you know what I mean?
- It's incredible.
- You didn't have a
regulation around that,
that you could just send a car into space?
You didn't wanna....
- No, no, no.
(laughing)
Yeah, no, it didn't
fall within our purview,
but certain other things
do fall within our purview.
So over the last two and a half years,
we were the first administration
to approve what are called
non-geostationary satellite
orbit constellations, NGSOs.
But essentially, a lot of satellites
that are being launched by companies,
like SpaceX and OneWeb,
and probably Kuiper,
Amazon in the future,
hundreds if not thousands
of these satellites in low earth orbits,
not deep into space, but
lower in the earth's orbits
so that they can beam
internet access services
at a speed and a price point
that would be comparable
to what you would get from
a terrestrial provider.
My position here is very
reflective of those principles
we talked about from the beginning.
Instead of preemptively regulating,
deciding, okay, you can launch,
but all of you, no, we're
not going to let you do it,
trying to pick a business
case or a business plan
that's going to work and letting
them take the first crack,
we're taking a more market-based approach.
Let's allow all of them to
launch in various stages
using certain parameters for
orbital safety and whatnot,
and see what happens.
Let's let the market, the
aggregated decisions of consumers,
decide which one will succeed.
Some of them might, you never know.
It could be a residential
broadband product.
Some of them are very different.
They wanna do industrial
internet of Things.
I met recently with a company
that just wants to deploy
150 satellites around the globe
and they wanna sign up customers
like say the Department of Defense
that has military all around the world,
and they just need essentially
low bandwidth services
just to let people know
where the troops are
at any given point in time.
We want all of them to be
able to succeed in space.
- It's funny, you don't really think
about the orbital safety portion of this,
as you just mentioned,
so it's almost like no
matter what happens,
you guys almost always need
another office to open, right?
I mean, is that sorta how it works?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you're like,
"All right, I want them to
put the satellites up there,
"we want to get people
internet as fast as possible
"and as cheap as possible, it's all good."
And then someone probably
walks in and is like,
"You know, we gotta make
sure these satellites
"aren't crashing into each other."
And then, what do you do?
You do another study?
What are you mapping out there even?
- That's a good question.
So that goes to the
earlier question you asked,
what if there were no regulations?
So here is where there is a base level
of regulation that's really important,
especially in the space environment.
For those of you who saw "Gravity"
with Sandra Bullock and George Clooney.
- Right, we can't have these things
just spinning around rocking each other.
- Exactly, because that stuff lasts
for thousands and thousands of years,
especially if they don't descend
in the atmosphere and burn up.
And so we wanna make sure
that that space environment
is safe for everybody.
And so one of the things I
kicked off about a year ago,
let's see how should we update
our orbital debris rules?
They were first adopted in 2004,
but back then we didn't
have a lot of satellites
up in space.
We're talking about a
lot more stuff in space,
and so accordingly I
think our old debris rules
need to be updated.
So we're in the middle of conversation now
about how should we think
about updating those rules,
requiring companies to be safe.
Should they have to deorbit
on a certain schedule,
use certain technology,
that kind of thing.
- So I assume you'd prefer that everything
has some sort of time limit
up there or something,
so that eventually it doesn't just become
space garbage somewhere?
- Yeah, that's one of the things--
- Now we're in "Futurama" or something.
- Yeah, exactly, that's one of the things
we're thinking about is
should there be a time limit,
should there be a built-in technology
so some of these satellites
can deorbit automatically
after a certain period of time,
or if there is a failure, they
will automatically deorbit,
things like that, and so
ultimately we wanna make sure
that everybody can succeed
in space in the long run.
We don't want to, like I said,
any of these orbital
slots, if you have debris,
that's a generational problem,
not just a multi-year problem.
- How much of this is
sort of longterm thinking,
say the way you would talk
about the climate change situation?
So it's sort of like you
can plot a certain degree,
but no matter how much you plot,
other countries, I mean
you just referenced China,
other countries are just gonna do things
the way they want and how complicated
that makes your job.
- It's incredible.
- Meaning you could do
everything exactly perfectly,
and still if some other country decides
to do whatever they want,
you still have all of those problems.
- That is a problem, so there is a lot
of international coordination
that has to happen,
especially when it
comes to orbital debris.
We're always working with
some of the other countries,
agencies, to make sure
we're all on the same page,
and there are international organizations
that deal specifically with this.
In fact, shortly coming up in Egypt,
there's a big quadrennial,
every four years they have this conference
to talk about spectrum issues,
and one of the issues is what spectrum
should be available for
satellite companies.
So in that context, we're always talking
about being on the same page on things
like orbital debris and
spectrum allocation.
But I think you raised
a really good point,
is that we could do everything correctly,
but other countries are
looking to take the lead
on things like artificial
intelligence and machine learning
or blockchain or quantum computing,
and we don't have
jurisdiction over all of it,
but to the extent we
can, we wanna make sure
we advance U.S. leadership
because I do think
there are some first mover advantages
to countries and to
sectors that really show
that they're willing to take the lead.
- All right, let's take this back
to this planet for a moment.
(laughing)
All right, let's really
dive into the tech stuff,
because it's obviously
near and dear to me.
Now first off, can you explain
how this is not fully your jurisdiction?
Because this is one of
the interesting things,
where I mentioned right before we started,
you've got Elizabeth Warren on the left
calling for big tech regulation,
you've got Tucker Carlson on the right
and it's like, all
right, that's a strange,
that's that little horseshoe
thing that everyone's going,
"Well, how did this end up happening
"that these two people want it?"
They want it for very different reasons.
But can you first explain
how this isn't exactly your jurisdiction?
'Cause I think everyone
sorta thinks it is.
When they say government involvement,
I think they mean the FCC.
- Yeah, they often do think the FCC,
and especially in the
context of some of the more
political salient issues, like
net neutrality they would.
So in a nutshell, under current law
as Congress has set it
forth for many, many years,
the FCC has jurisdiction
over the networks themselves,
the guts of the networks.
We don't necessarily have jurisdiction,
or we don't have jurisdiction
over the content companies
that ride over those networks,
and so we don't directly--
- So the infrastructure
basically, the pipes.
- Yes, exactly, so the infrastructure,
not so much the content
that goes over those pipes.
And so that's the fundamental distinction.
To the extent that an agency
does have jurisdiction,
primarily the Federal Trade Commission
and the Department of
Justice, each of which
is now taking a look at some
of those tech companies.
- Yeah, what is your, I mean,
I don't know if you can speak
to this as the chairman of the FCC,
but what do you sort
of see as the right way
to deal with the censorship issues,
the shadow banning,
algorithm manipulations,
suppressing search results,
all of these things?
Do you have a general philosophy
on how to deal with this?
- I think that obviously
these companies have thrived
with a more light touch approach,
but a couple of years ago, I did flag,
before it was cool, I
will note by the way,
(Dave laughing)
I did flag the fact that consumers
legitimately had some
concerns, as did lawmakers,
about the lack of transparency
on how some of these companies operated.
We don't have insight into how Facebook
orders articles in its newsfeed.
We didn't have insight into how Twitter
might decide to organize Twitter moments,
or with Google and YouTube,
we didn't have insight into demonetization
and things like that, and I said,
"Look, we need to have a
consistent level of regulation
"across the entire internet economy.
"It shouldn't matter whether
you're a network operator
"or a content provider, for example,
"when it comes to privacy."
As an online consumer, I don't care
whether it's a network
company or a content provider
that has my sensitive information.
I want that information to be protected.
I called a couple of years
ago for a conversation
about how should we think
about the tech sector,
some of these tech giants
that have been completely unregulated.
And now it's interesting
to see, as you mentioned,
people from across the political spectrum
are reaching this sort of odd consensus
that something needs to be done.
What that something
is, I don't quite know,
and it's up to Congress to say,
but it is interesting how the conversation
has evolved here the last couple of years.
- Is this becoming one of the weird ones
that you sorta referenced before
where in a weird way,
the big boys in the game,
they kinda do want regulation now
because they know that
they'll be able to survive.
Google's got a lotta lawyers,
but that the new guys coming up,
once there's more regulation,
they're gonna have to
hit certain benchmarks
to do certain things, and they
just won't be able to do it.
And also possibly that the
problems are now so huge,
especially around free speech,
that it's like please regulate us.
That way we don't have to
think about the problems.
- It is very curious
how things have changed.
So some of those companies
were strongly advocating
for net neutrality regulations
coming from Washington,
heavy-handed regulations applied
to some of their network operator rivals.
When California in particular
passed a law on this subject,
those companies were very much behind it.
But now the table somewhat turns.
California's passed this
stringent privacy law,
those very same companies
are coming to Washington
and telling Congress, "We
need a federal privacy law
"in order to get rid of this
patchwork of state regulation."
And I always say, under the
well-established precedent
of goose versus gander, you
can't have it both ways.
(Dave laughing)
You have to be able to be
intellectually consistent
on this issue, and that's
part of the reason why
on net neutrality, on privacy,
on any of these issues,
let's just have an open
intellectually honest conversation
about how to establish a
consistent level of regulation
that protects consumers and competition
across the entire internet economy.
- I have to write that one down.
I'm not familiar with goose versus gander.
(laughing)
I'll make a note of that one
to check that one out later.
- I don't have a copyright
on it yet, but stay tuned.
(laughing)
- Okay, so let's back up,
'cause you mentioned net
neutrality a couple of times.
Now about a year and a half ago or so,
when net neutrality disappeared,
if you were paying attention
to the sorta mainstream
take on it, this was it.
World War III was starting,
the internet was over,
nobody was gonna get video,
everybody was gonna be throttled,
corporations were gonna take over.
Here we are.
- It's amazing.
- All right, can you
absolutely just for the people
that really want just like the
cleanest clearest explanation
so we can clip this perfectly,
what was net neutrality
and what actually happened?
- So net neutrality involves
the basic question of how,
if at all, should the FCC
treat internet access.
Should it regulate it under
what is called Title II,
which was the 1930s
regulations that were developed
to regulate Ma Ball, the
old telephone monopoly,
or should it regulate the
internet under Title I,
the more market-based approach
that governed the internet
from 1996 until 2015?
My view is the market-based
approach served us very well.
We got $1.5 trillion of
network investment companies,
like some of those that we've mentioned
becoming giants from startups,
and consumers benefiting
from all that innovation.
At the end of the day,
I look at the evidence
that's in the record.
When we made our decision of 2017,
I kept track of some of those predictions.
You're going to have to pay $5 per tweet.
You're not going to be
allowed to post on Instagram.
One of my favorites, the
Senate Democratic Caucus
Twitter account said
the internet will work
one word at a time.
Or one of my favorites, this
is the end of the internet
as we know it.
Well, fast forward to now.
Internet speeds in the United States
on average are up over 50%,
network investments in
2018 was up $3 billion,
the second in consecutive increase,
more fiber was deployed in 2018
than in any year since
they've been keeping records,
and venture capital, funding
startups, set a record in 2018.
And one wouldn't expect
that if these internet
service providers were in
fact acting as a gatekeeper,
chocking off innovation.
So to those critics out there,
I would say the record is clear.
The internet is more open than ever,
and thanks to our decision,
more people than ever before,
faster than ever before,
can hate tweet their
favorite FCC chairman.
So I think it's a
testament to our success.
- Right, so you got an
unbelievable amount of hate
during that time.
- Oh my god, yeah, no kidding.
- That might have led
you to wanna regulate
some of this a little bit more.
But I guess you stuck with your ideal.
- Yeah, no, we did, and
there was a lot of pressure
on the other side, no question about it,
and personal threats made
against me and my family
and even the agency itself.
There are people in jail today
for threatening my family and the agency.
But at the end of the day,
I really have the conviction
that we were doing the right thing.
I've got a quote by my computer
and I see it every single
day when I power up,
and it's from Churchill back in the '20s.
It said, hear this, young men and women,
and proclaim it far and wide,
the earth is yours and
the fullness thereof.
Be kind, but be fierce.
You are needed now more than ever before.
Take up the mantle of
change, for now is your time.
And I know it sounds cheesy,
but I really do try to embrace that ethos
that you've gotta know what you believe
and you've got to execute on that belief
to the best of your ability
and take the arrows that come with it.
Is it going to be popular always?
No, not at all.
I mean, I understand a lot of people
still are angry about this decision.
But at the end of the day,
I've got the longterm in mind,
and the longterm is one in
which the digital divide closes,
everyone's connected with the internet,
the internet is free and open,
and that's the vision that
we're gonna continue to execute.
- Do you think just to
sorta give the people
that want it to keep
net neutrality in place,
to give the devil his due let's say,
do you think that it's just a
fundamental misunderstanding
of what companies do?
The fears seem to be that
if you don't regulate them
in this way that one company
will slow down Netflix
and the other one will speed
up their own broadband service
and all of these things.
And there is some like initial thought
that kinda makes sense there,
like you would wanna hurt your competitors
if you're in several businesses,
and you'd wanna help your partners,
but that's not really
how competition works.
And I guess everything
that you just laid out
is sorta proof of that.
Do you think that they
just sort of fundamentally
misunderstand economics
or something like that?
- I understand the concern they
might have in the abstract,
but the two things I
always try to emphasize
to allay those concerns are, number one,
I support Congress putting
on the page in the modern era
what the rules of the road should be.
It's a one-page bill, honestly,
that Congress could pass tomorrow.
No blocking of lawful
content on the internet,
no throttling of lawful content,
no anti-competitive paid prioritization.
Transparency, make sure every
internet service provider
documents all its business and
network management practices
for everyone to see.
I've just outlined a 99% supportable bill,
but that's never going to happen because--
- There's no such thing
as a one-page paper.
(laughing)
Come on, you gotta add in what,
like 5,000 more pages.
- Yeah, all the wherefores.
And 27 bills that have to do with farming.
- Exactly, but this is a very simple bill
that I would support.
I think most members of
Congress would support.
But the political impulses from those
who really rabidly want
heavy-handed regulation,
they're never going to
allow that to happen.
The second thing I emphasize is,
look, antitrust and
competition law has long been
a very steadfast protector
of competition in this area,
the FTC and the Department
of Justice in particular.
The internet didn't die from 1996 to 2015
when we had this exact same framework.
To the contrary, it thrived
with a market-based approach.
And just think about what
the internet would have been
if we had treated it like Ma Bell.
You would have an internet
that was just as reliable as Amtrak,
as popular as the post office,
as efficient as the DMV.
That is the model that some
people want to return to,
and to me, that's not good enough.
American consumers
deserve better than that.
- I'm sure you've heard about this sort of
platform verse publisher debate.
That's about the stupidest
question I've ever asked,
and I'm going to go there.
- No, not at all.
- I'm gonna go out on a limb
and assume you've heard about this debate.
So for me, as a guy that wants
as little regulation as possible,
so I totally hear your philosophy on this,
the platform verse publisher one
is starting to make sense to me.
This is a place where I
could start seeing a need
for regulation because if
you're just a platform,
then you should have to do all the things
that you want in your one-pager.
But if you're a publisher,
then you have those
extra responsibilities.
Yet in a weird way, the platforms,
say Twitter, YouTube, Facebook,
are behaving like publishers
and not platforms.
How complex is all of this to unpack?
- It's exceptionally complex,
and one of the fascinating things to watch
from my vantage point is on Capitol Hill,
you're now seeing
Republicans and Democrats
openly wondering should
we change the laws?
Let's hold hearings to examine
how we should change the laws
to accommodate this new understanding.
Everything seems to be
up for grabs right now,
and I'm now sure how
it's going to play out,
but that debate of
platform versus publisher
is something that I think
was pretty much unthinkable
just five years ago, so I'm not
sure where it's going to go,
but we're certainly watching it.
- Do you think it's possible
that there are certain things
that the government is just
no longer equipped to handle?
That the power and the
amount of information,
the amount of technology
that Google let's say controls right now,
is so awesome and unprecedented,
that the idea that a government
regulatory commission
could actually harness
it, fully understand it,
and fully guide it in the right way,
that that almost is impossible?
- That's a really good question.
- That must be a pretty
crappy thing to think about,
I suppose, given your position.
(laughing)
But I mean, do you think that is possible,
that these companies have grown in ways,
like the amount of power that Google has
is way more than Ma Bell had in 1930,
and government obviously
changes much slower
than a technology company can.
- That's a good question.
I'd have to think about
it a little deeper.
I would say the first
cut, I do think the tools
of antitrust and competition
law are fairly well-suited
to deal with companies
that may have market power.
The Standard Oils of yesteryear
could just have easily,
that framework could just as easily apply
to the tech giants of today
and to evaluate whether or not
they are posing an
anti-competitive threat.
What I would say is the central problem
we haven't yet wrestled with
is that the pace of
technological innovation
is quickening, if anything,
and we're now rapidly
dealing with not just laws
that are out of date, but a Congress
that in a regulatory structure
that isn't equipped to deal nimbly
with some of the challenges.
To give you one example,
facial recognition technology.
You're now seeing a lot
of people wondering,
well, should we ban or should we regulate
facial recognition technology?
How does it work?
Or cryptocurrencies, you
see regulators struggling
with how should we think about this?
Is it another financial instrument
that we should regulate
under the old laws,
or should we just come
up with something new?
Across all of these different sectors,
the pace is so fast that by the time
we even understand what it is,
it's just almost too
late to pass regulations
because the marketplace
has moved beyond it.
So I think that is one
of the central problems
that we haven't yet grappled with.
- Is the other part just
that administrations
change pretty quickly?
We don't know who the president's gonna be
in about a year and a half
from now, we just don't.
And the next person could
come in, and is your term,
is that just on the
decision of the president
or does that relate to your term?
- No, so every chairman is a commissioner,
so I have a commissioner
term that ends in 2022,
but by law the president has to designate
whoever the chairman is at
any given point in time.
So yeah, I do, I have a
term that runs independent
of the presidential administration
that happens to be in power.
- But technically the next
president could just take you
outta that term.
- Exactly.
- So how much of your
consideration has to do
with just the political
realities of all of this?
- To me, zero.
One of the great things about
being an independent agency
is that we make the decision
that we think is the right one.
Generally speaking, our
initiatives have been nonpartisan
in nature, to me at least.
Getting broadband to rural
Americans and tribal Americans
is not a Republican issue
or Democratic issue,
it's just an American issue.
Getting people with disabilities
access to technology,
helping people in hurricane ravished areas
is not a partisan issue as well.
5G is a national imperative.
So a lot of these things are
actually bipartisan in nature
or nonpartisan I would
say, and so to me at least,
that's how I tried to embrace the job.
And the other thing that goes unremarked
in Washington at least,
is as far as we can tell
I'm the first chairman in history ever
to ask each one of the commissioners,
Republican and Democrat,
to take leadership
to speak for the agency
on an issue of importance.
Traditionally, the chairman essentially
hogs all of the responsibility
for himself or herself,
but I've tried to delegate a lot of that
to make sure that all
of them feel empowered.
That's good for them, but
it's also good for the agency
to show that, look, we're
not a political agency
that rises or falls based
on where the political winds
may happen to take us.
- You must be pretty enthused
that things like this exist
for you to get your message out
versus in the old days.
- Oh my god.
- To the extent that
somebody might wanna hear
some wonky stuff from the FCC chairman,
it was basically done on a five-minute
Sunday morning talk show.
- Oh yeah.
- And it's like now you can actually
really expand on these things.
- That's why I'm so grateful
to outlets like this one.
I'm telling you, as somebody,
I mean, a lot of your viewers
are probably much younger than me,
but as somebody who
grew up in the late '70s
and early '80s in rural Kansas,
there were very few
ways to get information
from the outside world, and virtually none
to get information translated from you
to get your voice heard.
So to go from that where we
were 30, 40 years ago to now
where essentially the internet
has democratized speech
in a way that is unthinkable,
is incredible to me.
One example I always use is I
was the first FCC commissioner
on Twitter back in 2012.
When I joined, some of my
colleagues said, "This is crazy."
- May God have mercy on your soul.
- "You shouldn't be doing this."
But now it's enabled me to
get the message out to people
who are never gonna be
able to come to Washington
or hire somebody to come to
Washington on their behalf.
It's had a real impact on my work
and my ability to get my voice out.
There are a few issues
that I've championed
that have been a result
of people tweeting at me
and I learn more about the issue
and we end up taking action that helps,
in this one case in
particular, save lives.
The 911 calling system,
we've improved thanks in part
to a tweet I got back in December of 2013.
- What was that?
What was the message?
- So December 1st of 2013,
a woman named Kari Hunt Dunn
was living in Marshall, Texas.
She and her three kids went
to visit her estranged husband
in a hotel room in Texas.
As soon as she got into the hotel room,
her husband started stabbing her,
and her nine-year-old daughter raced
to the hotel room's phone
and started dialing 911,
as everybody knows, but
the call didn't go through.
She dialed 911 once
again, and one more time,
and one more time.
She didn't realize she
had to dial nine first
to reach an outside line.
So the story made the
local press down there.
Somebody tweeted the story at
me, and I started reading up
and I thought, boy,
that raised my antenna.
What's the situation of 911
calling around the country?
So two weeks later, I was
on the phone with Hank Hunt
who was Kari's father.
I talked to him about the situation.
A month later, I sent a letter to the CEOs
of the top 10 hotel chains
in the United States,
as well as the Hotel
and Lodging Association.
A year after that, I stood
next to Hank in Marshall, Texas
where we updated the American public
on the progress we had made.
And last year, I stood with
Hank in the Oval Office
as the president signed legislation
named Kari's Law, after his late daughter,
to establish no access code required,
legislation that would essentially
allow direct access to 911.
And so to me at least,
I know Twitter has been a plus and a minus
for many, many people, but
to me at least that story,
it really vindicates the power
of an individual like Hank
to get his story out there
and to effect meaningful social change.
- Yeah, I mean, that's pretty incredible,
and actually the way you just laid it out,
even with the dates,
I mean, you guys moved
pretty quick on this.
That doesn't sound like a kinda
governmental thing, right,
like within a year or so.
- One thing I think people appreciate,
whether they like or don't
like the policies we pursue,
is I tend to be a pretty energetic person.
I wanna get things done and
I have an impatience about me
that forces me to wanna take
action as quick as possible.
So on an issue like that, which
naturally it sounds right,
'cause no kid would think
that they have to...
Many adults wouldn't realize
you have to press nine
to get the outside number.
Did you get any pushback
from the industry,
that was like, "We don't
want outside access"
or something like that?
I mean, what would be the
pushback on something like that?
- There wasn't a lot of pushback.
It was more how difficult
would it be to retrofit
some of the old telephone systems,
or is the government going to mandate
specific technology to be used?
I think they were
generally very supportive,
and what I found in talking
to some of the hotel owners
and phone manufacturers is
as soon as they became aware
of the issue, they were more
than willing to make a change.
In many cases, it doesn't cost any money.
It's essentially just flipping
a switch, so to speak,
in terms of software and you
get rid of that access code.
To me, it's really gratifying.
Whenever I check into a hotel room now
I always look at the phone
as soon as I put down my key,
and it's great to see,
to reach emergency
services, just dial 911.
Millions of Americans who
check into hotel rooms
will never know that the FCC,
that Hank had a part in that,
but it goes to that point
you were making earlier,
that the longer term
value that we delivered,
even if it doesn't get attributed to us,
it really makes me feel good to know
that we made a positive difference.
So you've mentioned Twitter,
the good and the bad Twitter,
a couple of times here.
We should relate some of this
to generally just the election,
'cause I don't know if you know this,
but we're in an election year now, right?
- Is that right?
- There's something coming.
- I had no idea.
- And all of the sort
of the hate and the good
and all of it, it's all kinda ramping up,
the censorship stuff and all of that.
Do you guys have anything directly to do
with when people say that Russian bots
were hacking the election
and manipulating news stories
and all of these things?
How much directly does that
fall under your purview?
- It doesn't, actually.
So we do follow, of course,
just in the popular press
some of the articles and
commentary that go on about that,
but that would be more within
the purview of other agencies.
Now I will say in terms of cybersecurity,
we do work with our other
federal partners very closely.
The Department of Homeland Security
in particular has an agency,
the Cybersecurity and Infrastructure
Security Agency, CISA,
and that's led by a
gentleman, Chris Krebs,
who I work with very regularly.
I just met with him last week
on some of the 5G security issues.
So to the extent that the
actual hacking of networks
is involved, we do have a seat
at the table, so to speak.
- Do you find that the other commissioners
that you have to work with
basically have a similar
philosophical leaning?
- I think so, generally speaking,
when it comes to security,
we're all on the same page.
We want these telecom
networks to be secure.
We might have different
answers on how to get there,
but ultimately, I think
we do share the same goal.
In fact, this is one of the issues.
I tapped one of my Democratic colleagues
to represent the agency at some
of these 5G security issues
precisely because I
recognize that the security
of these 5G networks is
not a Republican issue,
not a Democratic issues.
It may raise some eyebrows,
"Why are you tapping somebody
"from the other party?"
but I think it's important for Americans
to speak with one voice on this issue,
and I'm more than happy
to share the credit.
If we get the ball across the goal line,
that's great if he can do it.
- Can you talk generally, I
think that's a good transition,
to just like what is the
culture in Washington right now?
Not even necessarily with your job,
but I think everyone's feeling this thing
that just the machine
kinda doesn't work anymore.
Everyone does everything
on partisan lines.
You just mentioned that
you try not to do that.
But just what is the culture?
As someone that lives
and works in Washington,
you're part of a machine that
administrations come and go,
you're still gonna be there,
and people are always talking
about that sorta thing now,
that the Washington
machine just always exists.
Can you just talk about
the culture a little bit?
- It's increasingly poisonous.
I have found that there's
much more tribalism
in Washington than ever before.
I'm not sure if it's a cause or an effect
of the tribalism we
see in our body politic
generally speaking, but
I do find it distressing
a lot of the times that
some of the blow back
I'll get on Twitter has
nothing to do with me,
it's just, "Oh, you're
part of the administration,
"screw you," and it's that
kind of knee-jerk tribalism,
and conversely on the other side, too.
If you're supporting one of the candidates
on the campaign trail, "Screw you,
"I don't wanna have
anything to do with you."
That kind of ethos has permeated
Washington to some extent.
It's unfortunate because I do think
that at the end of the day
there are certain things
that we did have a consensus on.
I mean, even the free market principle,
it was not that long ago
that I think we had--
- Is that the most shocking one to you?
'Cause that one seemed so bizarre to me,
that we're debating things that have led
to all of the success that
we all live in right now,
and we're suddenly just
tossing it up there
as if these things should be debated.
- It would be a close second
I would say to free speech.
That's one of the issues that I think
I have often said it
distinguishes American democracy
from virtually any other society
in the world today or even in history.
I always say that free speech
is not just the cold guarantee
that's on the partron of the Constitution.
It's also a culture that
emerged for many, many years
with great sacrifice.
If you have a view that
is opposed to mine,
the tradition of course was,
what's that saying that's
attributed to Voltaire?
I may disagree with what you say,
but I'll fight for your right to say it.
Increasingly, we see that, no,
people want to wall off the public square,
in fact push people out of
the public square altogether
if there's a dissimilarity of views.
That is something that
is extremely dangerous
to this country.
- Have you thought of one
of the interesting ideas
that I've heard related to just backing up
to the platforms themselves
is that since these are private companies,
that it's almost like let them do
whatever they want, basically,
but that then the government
could actually get involved
in creating a platform that would respect
all of the laws of the United States,
and that that would be an interesting use
of government money, because it's like,
oh, all right, Twitter
can do what they want,
YouTube can do what they want,
but what if the government
actually just had a platform
that as long as you're abiding
by the laws of the United States,
basically you are allowed to be on there,
something like that.
- I'd have to think about it more deeply.
I guess two of my concerns would be,
number one, the government
generally speaking
is not well-positioned to own and operate
a platform like that.
- Be creating all of that.
- And the second one would be,
as we saw with the debates
over the Fairness Doctrine
in the 1970s and 1980s, that
that doctrine was misnamed
precisely because it
empowered government officials
to decide, to essentially assign points
based on what side of the
political ledger you were on.
And that is the kind of thing that worry--
- So basically it was
the unfairness doctrine.
People think, well, it sounded right,
I mean, it's what they do with everything,
it sounds right, the Fairness Doctrine.
We're gonna have everybody's
ideas be out there equally,
but at the end of the day,
if the market doesn't,
if some people just don't
care about your ideas,
why should the government
be propping you up,
and that's what it was doing, right?
- Yeah, that's always one of my concerns.
The same thing when it
come to spending money.
If somebody tells me, "Oh, this
service or product is free,"
well, sometimes the only problem with free
is that it costs too much
and you have to always
look at the fine print.
So too when it comes
to free speech issues.
I do think that's one of the issues
I have to think a little
more deeply about,
but that would be my instant reaction.
- So are you hopeful then that
our defense of free speech
will continue and that
we're gonna maintain
this rare First Amendment
thing that we've got,
that is the jealousy of the world?
- I don't know, so when I
travel around the country,
and I've now been to all 48
states in the continental U.S.
and Puerto Rico and the Virgin Islands,
and you meet people who are just trying
to put food on the table, work hard,
and raise their families, you get a sense
that that bedrock understanding
of America's commitment
to free speech is still strong.
But my god, when you see some of these
controversies emerging
on college campuses,
on internet platforms like
Twitter, it does make you worry,
are we going to have a
generation of leaders
that is committed to that
ideal, and I don't know.
I mean, I hope so, and I think
it does rub a lot of people
of good will on both sides the wrong way
to know that there are
certain correct views
and only those views should
be heard in the public square.
Because one day your views
might be viewed as incorrect.
- [Dave] I know the feeling.
(laughing)
- I don't know, I guess this might be
the naive Kansan in me, but
I really do feel optimistic
that that instinct that runs
deep in the American psyche
is going to win out in the long run,
but there is some very
determined opponents
on the other side, to be sure.
- So we talked about a couple
of the future things here.
So we're building this 5G network,
we talked about space a little bit,
but just to wrap us up nicely,
what else should we be thinking about?
What are the other things
that are on the horizon for you guys
that maybe the average
person isn't thinking about,
that if we started thinking
about it a little more clearly,
we wouldn't be in the, oh,
net neutrality's going away,
the world is gonna end tomorrow.
So let's do a little
buffering for the future here.
(laughing)
- So the biggest thing we're--
- And if you answer this right.
- [Ajit] Ah, all right.
- I'll give you a Reese's.
I'll even put the Reese's back down there.
- This sort of Pavlovian bribery
is gonna get you nowhere, my friend.
(laughing)
No, I think in conjunction
with the great work
we're doing on 5G and
closing the digital divide,
the one thing I would flag for
people is how that interacts
with artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
The networks of the future are
going to be smart networks.
It's not going to be a
person operating locally
managing a network.
It's going to be software
using algorithms to decide
how best to optimize that network.
One of the things we've been doing,
we just held the first
ever forum in the FCC
on artificial intelligence
and machine learning
last December, and I've been working
with a lot of entrepreneurs on this
to try to figure out what is the future?
Not just the automation of jobs,
but how will it make us smarter?
For example, if you're
talking about wireless sensors
that patients might wear,
even when they're not in the hospital,
and those sensors could transmit
at very low bandwidth
amounts of information,
your vital signs and what not,
an algorithm could analyze it very quickly
to determine if a healthcare provider
needs to intervene quicker.
That's the kind of thing we're
looking at in the future.
The same thing when it come to even things
like precision agriculture,
believe it or not,
incredibly connected farms
that are gonna require
AI and machine learning
tools to figure out,
buys in the square foot,
where do we need to apply fertilizer
and where don't we need
to apply fertilizer?
Across all of these industries,
AI and machine learning
is gonna have a huge
transformative effect.
I don't know what the future is,
but I do think it's important
for us to think about it.
I didn't mean to gloss
over the automation factor.
That's another thing as well
that I hear some concern about.
If you're a long-haul trucker,
or even a lawyer, or a pharmacist,
increasingly those jobs
are getting disrupted,
and I do think it's important
to have a conversation
about the future of work.
That's not necessarily
the FCC's bailiwick,
but I do think it's a
larger social phenomenon
that some people are worried about,
some people are optimistic about,
and I'm not sure where
the conversation will go,
but it's important to have.
- Since you made a Yoda reference before,
I really thought you were gonna drop
a "Skynet Terminator" reference there.
(laughing)
But I mean, really, that is it,
like how much power will
we give to the machines,
and does the day come when
suddenly they're in charge,
and then they go, "Huh, well,
"the humans should
probably have less power."
- Yeah, I was joking with one
of my friends the other day.
I don't know if you saw "Wall-E"
way back when.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Is it gonna be like "Wall-E"
or the "Matrix," the worse case.
"Wall-E" where they do
all the work for us,
"Matrix" we're essentially
batteries for everybody else.
- I mean, I'm pretty
sure we're in some mix
of both of those right now.
- It's turtles all the
way down, my friends.
(laughing)
- It's been a pleasure chatting with you.
Thanks for coming in.
And you guys can follow
Chairman Pai on Twitter.
Tell him everything that you
think about net neutrality,
the good, bad, and the ugly.
I apologize for that.
(Ajit laughing)
@ajitpaifcc.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.